تؤكد ن حماس تؤكد اختيال صالح العاروري
اذا حركه حماس تؤكد اذا تاكد رسميا من
خلال اعلان حركه حماس بان صالح العاروري
القيادي في حركه حماس قد تم اغتياله وهنا
لابس انه عرف الجمهور
بصالح العاروري وهو قيادي سياسي وعسكري
فلسطيني بارس في حركه حماس هو نائب رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس
ا ساهم بتاسيس كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحماس في الضفه و يوصف بانه من
الرؤوس المدبره لتسليح كتائب القسام كان
قد اعتقل وقضى نحو 15 عام 15 عاما في سجون
الاحتلال ثم ابعد عن فلسطين واتجه الى
لبنان وكان احد اعضاء الفريق المفاوض
لاتمام صفقه وفاء الاحرار صفقه شليط
المعروفه بصفقه شليط وهو متزوج وله ابنتان
و كان يعيش قبل اغتياله في لبنان